So by to you know just.
Asking. I ask you why. Do you happen to.
A r p a n a.
Nine and graham asking.
I came to newcastle.
Where i was a marine engineer.
And the reason i ended
up in the north coast.
Was i got busted for smoking
dope and sacked from the pay.
And i spent a little
bit of time in sydney.
After that which i hated when a friend
of mine dropped around one night
and said he just bought a health
food restaurant in bangalore
and dangle out then it down the back of
my mind for years because we travelled up
here on holidays the child and i
remember bangalow just doing it.
I think a little too. Which is still
used. And i wasn't doing anything else.
And so i came up and worked in
his restaurant at the time.
Was probably the only drama north coast.
There's one in byron bay
and i worked there for about three months.
And that was because my friend was away
doing a different job filling in for him
and i just heard of a farmhouse to rent a
place go berrying about to close to my
well under $4 a week.
And so i went live there and i
found. One fall in the paradise.
There was one other household of people
from sydney which was at that instance
that i referred to before and
and wonderfully well welcoming
rural people who offered jobs.
Gave us free food etc..
And at the time
that was the time of the whole earth
catalog everyone had a whole earth catalog
and we also we were getting away
from big city life more simple life
rural existence.
Which was totally true
and existed in this marvelously
bucolic existence.
Until the dreaded aquarius first.
And i think at that time was.
We shouldn't tell anyone else
and keep it very quiet. Because.
I could see that. The easy life.
We were having would be sort of moral
is taken away became more popular.
And that's turned out something like that.
I guess but it's been good.
And how i fit in with the aquarian people.
And their sort of people i like to mix
with but i don't think like you know.
And they're more straightforward and
scientific way of looking at things.
I guess that's because my
engineering background. That.
It's all been good fun.
At the time it was.
Out. I'm judy arpanet. And i.
Left melbourne in 1970 to early 1970 to
with my partner of the time
and my daughter portia
and we decided to go on the road.
We sold everything and given
away all our possessions.
We could quiet a tent a four wheel drive
and we'd taken about nine months
to get up from victoria up to here
and we camped along the way in the murray
river for several months and explored
and we were on our way around australia.
We had friends up on the north coast.
So we decided to call in and see them
and one of them happened to be living
in barring bar where graeme was living.
The day we drove into mullumbimby
was a wonderful day.
We drove up into cooper's lane
and the local alternate people were having
what we used to have in those days which
was a barter we'd gather together
and we'd swap whatever we had which ranged
from sort of bush nuts to wild cucumbers
to food or bread that somebody had
baked or fruit and vegetables
that people had picked clothes that
they'd bought back from india.
So you could go shopping at the
barter with your parties and all
and come home with clothes and fruit
and vegetables and various things and
that was a very welcoming group of people
and they showed us where
we could put up a tent.
I asked somebody how difficult
it was to find a house
and she said well it's
actually quite difficult.
You usually have to wait a couple of
weeks which delighted me and i ended up.
We ended up having a lovely farmhouse there
for several months. During that time.
People started talking about this
gathering that was going to happen in
and none of us knew where neumann was
it was somewhere over the mountain so.
One by one we drifted over to nimbin.
Most of us knew somebody
who was already agony
and then these people had
come back over to the coast
and say oh well it's quite exciting.
What's happening over in yemen and so
and so there and they're doing this and
that so we decided sort of
collectively that we would go over
and join this festival. So we
gathered together a tribe and.
We were fairly anxious about this festival
and we weren't sure how many people were
going to descend upon this place so we
decided to rent our own little piece of
land attached to the main festival site.
This became known as the magic circle.
And so we also built our little
dwellings my tent was actually
the most. Weatherproof and at one stage
it rained just before the festival
and i had 30 people in my tent.
So.
That put us on alert
and people made slightly more weatherproof
dwellings out of plastic and bits
and pieces and bamboo and
grass and various things so
and a few people had tea parties.
As the original magic circle inhabit
and settled in all our
friends started to arrive.
We'd also set up our own food line
where we hired a truck and decided
that if a million people
descended we could still get out
and get up to the brisbane market to bring
back the fresh fruit and vegetables.
This didn't really need.
Need to happen because in fact
it was very well organised
and the amount of people that arrived
seemed to be the right amount.
It was a very exciting time being there
for a few weeks before the festival.
Just as a few more people drifted
in and the constant change
that started to happen. We started off
as a couple of hundred people and.
As the festival got closer you could.
The excitement and the unknown.
What was going to happen.
Were thousands of people going to
descend or the tens of thousands
or merely hundreds and that unknown
element was very exciting.
So we had all these contingency plan set.
And as the festival just
grew it was quite organic.
And very exciting to just walk around
the festival site and there was music
and alternative healing and various
friends of friends turning up
and discovering that you were connected
and knew all these other people who
also knew all these other people so.
One of the exciting parts was when the.
Feeble foundry bus arrived
from melbourne with.
Close to 40 or 50 people
on board with children
and musical instruments
and beautiful songs
and also their wonderful skill
and knowledge of baking wholesome
bread and cakes and so forth.
They took over the local bakery
and supplied the whole festival.
With wonderful goodies.
The high was. One memory i.
Very clear to me during the first of all
was i was walking down the road from the
magic circle toward the main.
Area and and there was doug anthony with
his wife margo and doug at the time was.
Leader of the country party
and he was dressed in
casual country party gear
and it long socks and sure
that he was looking quite relaxed in
didn't have any minders where there is no
mobile phone.
And it's just it's just another example
of how tolerant the local people are.
Of daag. Drugs or art. Yes.
Yes one of my memories was just
before the festival began.
I was walking down the road
and i met two old brothers they
were men in their seventies
or eighties who'd been born in
and they invited us in for a cup
of tea and bread and butter
and so we wafted in and we probably had
very little clothes on. I can't remember.
I think we put a sarong on when we
actually went out of the magic circle
and i remember sitting on their veranda
looking down onto the festival site
and talking to these men about their
feelings of what was happening in their
isolated little country town
they were they were delighted
and thrilled to them it was
like there were young people
and their their home was being
discovered and nurtured
and they were very positive about it but
i thought it was a really good thing
that was happening. I assume
those men are no longer alive.
20 years later but it was
really lovely to make
that connection with people
who'd been born there and seen
and go from quite a lucrative
farming community to a dying town
after the money is gone out of dairy
industry and they were delighted that young.
People were discovering
their area and to them it.
It represented life issues.
That.
We didn't start and him and
we weren't living in them
and we were living in barring that
we went back to burying that.
But after about three years of four years
of living on almost no money whatsoever.
I decided i can get a job. And.
I worked on.
First of all the queensland state
government ship and torres strait
and then later on on prawn trawlers
mcgovern carpentaria. And.
And smallest ended my connection with the.
Back to the earth movement. And
i never money out of that.
And i continue my relationship with
judy and i are expecting a child and.
We went totally against the trend again
and bought a house. In dreaded lid more.
And all our friends living in
the hill thought we were crazy.
But however since then friends
have also been forced to get jobs
and i've also ended up by cows in lismore.
And after the first of all
we went back to mullumbimby
but i was still in my gipsy mode.
So we packed our tent once again and headed
for north queensland where we spent.
Six or eight months.
That was in 74 flood.
And it was very wild up in
north queensland in a tent.
So we came back down to barring bar
with a cyclone one day in front of it
and a cyclone one day behind us being
stopped every hundred kilometres by floods
across the road. It was
a very exciting time.
Because you kept on meeting up with
the same people at the same flood.
I came back to the bearing bar valley
and a friend of mine had just moved out
of her farmhouse and gave it to me.
We lived there for two years. My
daughter went to school there.
I got a little bit of work picking
tomatoes for local farmers. And.
I by
that time had saved enough money through
the work to go to india i discovered
thabet and buddhism by that time and. I
was invited to on the monastery in nepal.
So i took my daughter who
was 12. By that time.
To india and we lived in fear and
europe for two and a half years.
A bit like graham going away broke my
connection with the back to the earth.
Movement and while i saw it
as a still a lovely ideal
and a lovely way to live circumstances
had changed and travel had changed me.
So i came back and worked on the prawn
trawler with graham for a little while
and.
That's when we really got
together and had a child
and lived in a little more for a year
or so because.
Here is. Well for me.
Nimbin is very much.
A place that i couldn't live in i
have many friends who live out there.
The aboriginal stories of
it being a ceremonial place
and not a place especially
for women to live.
It's very true
and real for me i find it very difficult
just to even drive to nimbin much easier
to drive over to the coast
but i have i love being close to nimbin
from a sociological point of view it is a
wonderful experiment and it has
really worked on many levels.
The levels that it's worked on and not
seen by many people who visit the town.
People tend to focus on the negative aspects
of this very small town with no back
streets. So everything
happens on the main street.
People are assumed that's all there
is to name and but in fact the way
that various communities have grown
and handle their own problems
and become self-sufficient and the way
that the children are looked after
and cared for and the
feeling of community.
I think is quite extraordinary and go fairly
unnoticed. Which may be a good thing.
Maybe that's why it works
that people are left alone out in the hills
to actually live out their dreams sort
out their problems. They're not a
drain on the local economy at all.
In fact they enhance it. And
i think in future years.
The communities and him and will be
used as a model to many other places.
It's been quite difficult
and the level of commitment of
people to live out their ideals
and their dreams is quite extraordinary.
And i can't think of anywhere else in
australia where people have actually cheevers
much as some of the communities
around women have achieved
and
that.
The advent of newman and the total
change in the population there.
Had had quite a profound
effect on local politics.
Many many proposals are going to lose more
council which there is no other council
would even think about doing and i
think it's mainly because the idea
that are being generated
in them and they're still.
A lot of conservative.
Sort of digging their heels in against
it that it will only continue and.
And i think.
I see the benefit of legal
counsel all around.
One of my notices memories of being in the
magic circle as one of the musicians in
the magic circle was a
man called call joseph
and we used to sort of a tradition developed
there where we'd wake everybody up in
the morning by going to just outside their
little dwelling and singing to them
and they would sort of
emerge out of their tents
and in the end there'd be a whole lot of
troupe of people couple of hundred people
all singing made a long
time sun shine upon you
and another song about
butterflies of paul and britain
and it was very idealistic
very pied piper ish
and it was a very lovely
way to start the day and.
I sway to wake up. The
truth at all. Very much.
The troubadour there was also a
wonderful french acrobat person high
type rope high wire
person called filippo t.
And he used to do shows
in the middle of nimbin
and put up a rope between
a hotel and a park
and walk on it with
umbrellas and on one leg
and the children were just entranced
absolutely entranced as were the adults.
But there was another troupe of people
from new zealand called blurter who were
again like theatre wandering
minstrel people they had a big bar.
And they used to put on shows
on the streets or in town
or around the festival site.
So there was a lot of the
troubadour feeling there
and a lot of freedom for people to
express themselves and take risks
and be creative and. There was very little
judgment. The children were really safe.
My daughter was about nine at the time
and i remember walking through
the festival with her one day
and she knew hundreds of people
and everywhere we went you'd
hear hi portia hi portia
and she just knew everyone from being.
In this very safe environment for
weeks and getting to know people
and she'd be fed by the hari krishnas
and she knew far more people than i did
and in fact
that was true of a lot of the children at
the time it was a very safe environment
and they could go off and do exciting
things and make movies and video
and travel around with musicians and.
There was a great feeling
of optimism for the future.
Washes up here in lismore.
The moment and it's just
become a mother herself.
As she was growing up into her
late teens and early twenties.
There was some feeling of why
didn't i get have a normal life
but as she got older. She's
been able to look back
and really appreciate the value of
the upbringing that she did have
and the freedom and the diversity
and one of her abilities
is to be very tolerant
and to be able to relate to many
many many different sorts of people.
So in fact i think it's helped her to
fit into society as it is today very
easily. I guess traveling overseas.
Help that process as well.
So it was quite influential for her.
It hasn't hindered her one of my
concerns as she got older idea i've been
irresponsible and i haven't prepared
her for university and life.
But in fact it's the opposite.
She's got a great ability to.
To survive survive well has very
clear values about what she wants
and what she doesn't want.
Yeah
that i guess it worked in a reverse way.
And other memory i have the first of all
we're spending about how morning up in a
tree. And tempting to put into practice.
Another person's idea what sort of shelter
you could make with a large flat sheet
of plastic. After several hours
and not being able to produce.
A shelter something like the
expo sale. Eventually made.
That's her a simple ridge pole tent.
Which she was rather take about at
the time but when the rain came down
and it was an approved be a
perfectly adequate shelter.
I think she was rather pleased.
With the way that.
Oh yeah and i also realize
that you can only fold a flat sheet
of paper a long straight line
that it can stretch and make the
marvelous shape that she had in my hand.
Right.
And practically have correct yeah.
However that the tent that i was
staying in was a friend of mine.
And it was a perfect had adequate
shelter. It was a. It was a parachute.
With a clip of it with
plastic conduit framing.
And you travel was the
parachute wasn't waterproofed.
You know.
It didn't work
that well i think it might
have ended up in judy's tent.
One of the characters i remember
in the magic circle was a public
though he me in character
called adrian rawlins
and adrian was part of the magic
circle and did various performances
and danced around and told lots of stories
and generally added a lot of color.
Yeah i won't tell you off by.
No. Call the.
Us. For or so past.
My name is paul burke
and i used to ride my motorbike
for nice rides up the coast road
and look at byron bay and marlin
the me and places like that
and i'd heard of this retreat.
That was set up on quite a few
hundred acres for gay men.
It was called mandala
and it was run by a man called david
johnson who was in the theater
and. I guess vegie garden and.
He had a concept that gay men
could actually come up here and.
Do meditation retreat and do gardening
and all sorts of alternative ways
of looking at their lives and.
So i first came up
and went to mandala i think it was the
spring 10 day spring retreat and.
It was fantastic. We worship the
goddess of selma and selma.
Would chant with selma and
chant the full moon up
and it was it was a nice experience
and a lot of the retreat the
david had with silent retreat.
And so i guess the aim was to
get to a spiritual higher.
Very similar to religious
retreat in a lot of ways
but in doing so we got really close
to one another and. Instead of.
The humbug rush of the city where you know
we really didn't get the one another.
Personally this place was great
for gay men to go along to
and to talk and discuss often.
Ourselves and to get to play
with the earth. Or you.
Miss would have been
in the early eighties.
Part. Yes. Oh yes most definitely.
It was an acceptance of men
sexuality gay men sexuality
and it made it a very safe place for us
to go and to talk about such things.
And it was a very open many doors for
me and i'm sure hundreds of other man.
I don't know how the news got around
the planet but often we'd go to.
Spring retreats or summer retreat and
there be men from germany and america
and so it soon become quite global. And it
was a wonderful place for men to go to.
From all over the world and this
actual. Country of our own.
Time. Yeah i'm not too sure
how it was advertised and.
But.
Word of mouth certainly got around
and there were lots of different types of
things we'd get up to like maypole and.
Yeah this chanting the moon up over
10 days and stuff like that was good
and powerful.
Yeah well i'd say it was one of the first.
Yeah. The. The hippie
movement were very excepting.
To the gay movement which was still very
young in this country at that stage
and. Yeah we felt very well
accepted in the community.
And.
And we also felt as though we could be
part of it with learning about gardening
and.
Ways of living in the country without a
pushbutton toilet and without electricity.
Those good good training for
us to move to the bush.
It gave us the insight
that we can live like this
and we can actually dig gardens
and do without the modern side of life.
Oh yeah.
Yeah well there's more and more i
believe gay men moving from melbourne
and sydney
and brisbane to this area
because one it's so beautiful
and to the nimbin people are
very very exacting to it.
And. I like the idea of walking
arm in arm with my lover.
Down in street and not having abuse
yelled out of the car windows
or people actually commenting
in a negative way.
You. Sure.
Well i've been on tangible now just for
12 months but yeah i deny the people
that are there i felt very at home there
and people are very
accepting to who i am and.
You know the colour is great out there
people from all over the world living there
now and i think that's added
to a lot of the colour
that they're in the children also aren't
little well there's not a lot of little
children like baby there now there's
actually young kids and teenagers
that have grown up there.
Which i've had no trouble with at all
when i pick them up on the motorbike
or in the car
or with whether they're galloping past
on the horses they've always got a smile
and.
Yeah it doesn't seem to be a heavy prejudice
coming from their parents about who we
should be or who we are
all don't talk to them.